[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 55 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
hi I'm Francis campo en I'm here with my
colleague mark Mandel hey Mark how are
you doing I'm good thanks francisc I'm
away from you at the moment still at I
know Francisco but I'll be joining you
in la shortly yeah i'm already in la la
office very nice office designed by
frank gehry nonetheless it's a pretty
nice place to be beach and everything
yep fancy so yeah see you soon but
before that we need to record an episode
so let's go with that we're going to
have an interview today I think it's a
very interesting interview we're going
to interview two members of the managed
infrastructure team at Google cloud
platform and I'm going to try to save
the names even though I'm sure I can I
fail this so we have Pavel and Jersey
Pavel crq [ __ ] and Jersey full easy
arch and I think that that is probably
the best I can do well we're gonna yeah
I think it's very good i'm pretty pretty
proud so yeah we're going to be
interviewing them about what is managed
infrastructure and why it is important
and why it could be it might be the good
solution for you so it's an interesting
episode absolutely i'm really interested
in very interesting you might want to go
back or not you specifically but someone
in the audience might want to go back
and listen to our episodes about
continuum of the cloud and maybe even
the google compute engine or virtual
machines episode as well they might
definitely relevant yeah i think that
the first episode episode number two was
about that was computed as a continuum
it was a very interesting episode and
maybe time to refresh it one day who
knows but before we stop refreshing any
episodes let's finish with this one yeah
so after the interview we have a
question of the week and it's about our
favorite topic ever for questions of the
week which is occurring at ease yep
always came to have communities about
how you can lock down your services
inside community so you can control who
can access them and whatnot yeah so
secure is security security but very
important but before that we're gonna go
with our cool things of the week and one
of the cool things of the week I think
it's really cool
for multiple reasons and kind of a geek
about this thing it's called time and
time is the kind of thing that's like oh
it's easy until you start doing time
zones and when you think time zones are
hard especially in Australia I don't
know what's going on in that country but
then you need to start thinking about
things like leap seconds and sit ellipse
leap seconds and stuff like that which
we will have one this year so we
actually open an API to do this yeah so
we now have across Google we have these
public and TP servers so if you haven't
ever used well you probably all have
used ntp but you don't realize it it's a
global services that are provided to
synchronize time across machines and we
now have these public ntp servers that
are available for you to use that do the
leap smearing for leap seconds so that
your machines don't do weird things when
they think 61 seconds is good time to
have in a minute yeah yeah it is it is
kind of cool there's a gift that I
really like which is that clock going
it's 2359 and 58 of the January not
December 31st and it goes 57 58 59 60 so
it counts like 61 seconds in a minute
which is actually what will happen this
year so yeah 2016 longer than expected
and it's a it's a really cool thing is
not only you get access to time that is
very precise you're actually using load
balancers so you get access to the
closest atomic clock in the data center
where your instance is running so it's
incredibly accurate that is very quiet
realized that was the case that's pretty
cool yeah probably probably way more
accurate that you will everything is
like yeah it is it is incredibly
powerful it's a very empowered clock yes
yeah so that's really cool i like the
second cool thing of the week because I
like fast hardware we have a strategic
alliance with Intel which is pretty
awesome and that means that we have
announced the upcoming xeon process
processor it's going to be available on
compute engine and other virtual
machines and available in Google cloud
platform so if you're keen to be on the
latest and greatest hardware
that strategic alliance is pretty
awesome cool and I see that it will yeah
it will be in all our flavors so
standard high man high cpu so it's going
to be like available for whatever you're
trying to do you're going to get to
access to pre amazing processors that is
very nice yeah it's actually really cool
also if you look into the Alliance
there's stuff in there about optimizing
communities for Intel Architecture
tensorflow IOT security like a lot of
really cool stuff nice and if you're
interested on joining the beta form
because it will be open sometime in 2017
it says early 2017 but if you're
interested in testing it there's a beta
program and we'll have a link to the
forum so you can apply to it from the
show notes so it sounds like it's time
for us to go talk managed infrastructure
with Pavel and Jersey why don't we go do
that letter that so I'm very pleased to
have two wonderful gentleman here with
us today to talk to us about an
interesting thing called managed
infrastructure we have two product
managers whose names I am most likely
going to massacre but I will try my very
best Pavel Shiva kovitch and Josie Oh
God uh forty oh it's is that even
remotely close pretty bad is that really
bad yeah yeah goes bad it's for chores
five you can totally go with it is much
better than any other flight attendants
goods are trying to take that how are
you both doing today puffle how you
doing very good thank you good and Josie
you seem to be doing well yeah it's good
absolutely so thank you so much for
joining us both of you i really
appreciate you both taking the time i'm
really excited about this conversation
before we get stuck into the details
though let's talk about who you are and
what you do here at Google puffle i'll
pick you at random how about you go
first sure so i actually started as a
programmer and spent most of my career
being a coder in the lead and a
technical director kind of that usual
path and then at some point i decided to
take a bit of a detour into business and
pure management but you know it turns
out i really just like building products
and ended up as a product manager at
Google and I've been here since the
beginning of 2016 excellent and New
Jersey so my my career actually sorry
several several years ago when I was a
nuclear physicist and then I moved to
the industry and work for several years
as a engineering director at motorola
and i moved to google where i was
initially working on google TV then on
google now and two years ago i move to
cloud cool cool is a that is a not very
traditional now a way to end up on a
managed infrastructure why don't you
tell us a bit about a little bit about
what is what do you mean by managed
infrastructure okay let me go first so
managed infrastructure is a suite of
products and features that are making
the life of a DevOps issue so we don't
you call it a zero DevOps notion raises
something where you really don't need to
worry about your infrastructure you can
focus just on your applications so in
terms of what we talked about in here we
look at two components one of which is
the manage instance groups I'll explain
the second what this is and the second
one is right sizing some medicines group
is a way of creating virtual machines in
a reputable way in the massive scale so
imagine you're running a service this
service or let's say it's a web service
and it has front-end running on a
virtual machine but as the load is
drawing you need more and more
connections handled and at some point
there is not enough that there is a
single machine so this system can be
built based on the manage instance group
and all of the logistics related to
adding instances removing instances
automatically is surveilled scalar the
fact that their capital life and their
recreated whenever there is any problem
is done by auto healer and then you can
deploy new version of the software using
outdated while your services are still
running so all of that the suite of
products we go managed infrastructure
and now the second piece of it is right
sizing it's a way for us to tell you
look you're our great customers
we don't want you to Overbay it's one
way of saying and the second is look we
really see that the setup on your
machine has too little of the memory or
not enough course to perform your task
so we catch you right size and
recommendations and a way to quickly
actuate it so tired that you are in a
good shape that's pretty much cool okay
so it sounds like all right so there's
there's basically it sounds like this is
a way to manage virtual machines in a
very elastic way that enables you to
scale excellent alright cool so I guess
my question at this point is okay what
sort of applications does this sort of
lend itself to is there a particular set
of types of applications or I don't know
what sort of like requirements or
restrictions is kind of fit into so in
terms of the applications that run well
on megs there is a couple of what it
would call kind of canonical typical use
cases that we see and there are some
that kind of spin out of that but let me
start with the the kind of the simple
typical use cases and the first one is
anything that serves traffic right so
typically that could be let's say a web
front-end that either connects to like a
phone application that was distributed
to your users or maybe it's a just a
classic store and what makes it really a
good match for managed instance groups
is that first of all it's your usage is
very dynamic right so as your traffic
grows with let's say that the local time
you need suddenly a lot more processing
as much as you know twice or ten times
as much as you need in your down times
and so you really want to take advantage
of this auto scaling right where as the
traffic is showing up in real time we'll
be creating machines in real time and
scaling up very very quickly so that you
can take your peaks and serve all of
your customers and then as soon as the
traffic stops we'll we'll get rid of
those machines right so you don't have
to be paying for resources you don't use
and typically those services are
stateless so these each machine can
basically be brought up and then
and it doesn't have any local state so
so it's very flexible that way and the
other use case that is a very good
attitude of MiG's is anything that can
or has to process let's say lots of data
in a distributed fashion so maybe you're
analyzing financial data so you have
10,000 stock quotes and each one can be
kind of analyzed independently so that
can be distributed over lots of machines
and then you want to do that as you
crunch through your data but the other
part of that workload is that it's very
much on demand right so new financial
data might show up or maybe you have a
new model that you want to analyze and
so you go from I need none of this
compute to I need all of the compute
immediately as soon as you can give it
to me to process through all of this
data kind of in parallel so the mid can
scale up very quickly and basically give
you all the machines you crunch to your
data and then it disappears another ucs
that's typical these things that are
working around image processing or so
maybe you're getting a data download of
you know satellite imagery or some other
some other imagery that comes maybe once
a week and so again you don't need these
machines you know six days of the week
but then one day of the week you need
all of them because you've got you know
terabytes of image data to crunch
through but each image can be processed
independently so that's a that's a
perfect use case so this is kind of like
distributed large-scale data processing
and then another aspect that's kind of
orthogonal to this but also important is
this idea of highly available services
so whether that's your web front end or
even your data processor you want to
make sure that the machines will recover
if they crash or hang or have some other
issues and you don't have to yourself go
in there and fix it so you know with
Auto healing you can monitor these
machines and if they run into trouble
your custom kind of health check will
report on that and the manage instance
group will take care of this and restart
the machine and then the other side of
the highly available equation is this
concept that if all your emachines are
in one's own our zones are stable but at
the same time out it just can't happen
and it is the best engineering practice
to say if you need a service to be
really really stable you don't want to
put all of your machines in a single
zone because things can happen
and so you want to spread it across
multiple zones and so now with a managed
instance group you can essentially
spread your machines evenly across three
zones so now you have something that's
called the regional manager instance
group and we take care of this problem
of balancing so we'll add machines and
remove them as needed so that each zone
is kind of even to the other zones so if
any one of them disappears you can route
your traffic automatically to the other
zones and not have any downtime so yeah
so it's anything that's basically
distributed independent stateless and
then how the available requirements is
is the additional piece interesting so
nowadays most people when they start
thinking about well you know I have
specific needs like you were mentioning
video processing or like a big data
processing that needs to be done quite
fast most people would think about using
things like guru Nettie's what what are
the differences what are the benefits of
using manage instance groups or managing
for structure as we call it over going
with something like urban areas or maybe
even App Engine flags all right so let
me take this one so all of these
products are we call them engines or
complementary so you first need to sort
from asking yourself a question how much
control do I want to get versus how much
control do I want you give out and then
we'll treat everything automatic right
and from that perspective you have three
choices right you have App Engine or App
Engine flags as one product it's best
for the web services of any kind it's
the easiest to start there is some
limitation to the languages that you can
possibly use but well you can you can
load your custom docker containers and
told it's it's the easiest way for you
to store it on this kind of services now
when you want some more control or when
you want to control the young calls to
perform
or when you want superfast autoscaler
right this or you factors where that
that would tip you towards the Google
compute engine so this is where you have
the management group acid as a base
service right so Google compute engine
or just your vm machines so compute
engine specifically is the platform on
which App Engine flex is its operating
and it's also a blood for on on h gu
burnett this is operating right so now
what Cooper net this is adding on top of
Google compute engine or manage instance
group is two factors right is the the
overall containers orchestration that
contains of two distinguishing factor
one of which is been packing and second
one is in general scheduling /
microservices so this two cannot be done
on any of these other platforms well
they come as a service and what you have
beneath is a cluster of machines and
this machines or likely run by dimension
scripts so i guess if we think about in
terms of like the compute continuum
right and and i'm far will say left pick
a direction that's like
platform-as-a-service App Engine far
right is like GCE like straight up
infrastructure this sort of sits I feel
like somewhere between KU brunette ease
and GCE like it sits in between those
two things where it's like it's not
entirely infrastructure-as-a-service and
it's not nearly as managed to say Cooper
entities but sort of sits in between and
gives you sort of a bit more flexibility
than say communities but a little bit
more that you need to manage yourself
would that be pretty accurate I think
it's very close I think you you have to
remember that mandich instance group is
GCE this is exactly where we see it it's
just just a layer of management on top
of GC but it's in terms of the
flexibility this is exactly where your
position it's like GK is is one more
level higher in terms of obstruction you
give up some of the control and you gain
a lot of management in terms of feel
packing tea and scheduling the
containers on
of a cluster of machines that you done
this need to manage yourself cool so
let's let's imagine that I decide to and
actually I've done it before I need a
cap I need a bunch of machines running a
imagemagick right and what I'm going to
do is I create a new instance and I
connect to it i do apt-get install
installing much magic and that now in so
much my software on top of it and
everything is really works now normally
if it wasn't cooper daddy's i could
create a docker image for that and sugar
around right how does that look on my
manage instance groups how do I make
sure that the new instances that come
into into my manager instance group have
the older software and all the features
that I require so actually this is very
good question so similarly to which you
can do on both up engine and Cooper
netis you can get your all of your
software into a docker container and
then deploy it into the bandage instance
group it's similar way the only
difference is is just sitting as one
container on top of your vm so in that
place comes the need for deciding very
well unlike house well your vm machine
can be so that your cost is optimized
everything else works the same and
really creating a managed instance group
is strictly defining what type of a
machine that want to run right and then
where do I pull my daugher contain it
from and once you have this two
parameters defined we defined them in it
something i would call instance template
then you can create a group and once we
have a group you can either tell it i
want 207,000 instances 2000 instances of
the same or you can enable auto scale
and say I want the average cpu
utilization to be around sixty percent
or you can enable auto here and say or
if i don't hear from this health check
three times in the row over 30 seconds
period considering unhealthy and please
recreate that instance for me
that it continues operating cool so that
the question are going to ask now it's
gonna make me look very bad but I
actually didn't know you could run
docker containers directly onto an
instant group do you need to choose a
specific image a specific OS or how does
that work well this is very new feature
it's actually enough so first of all you
have to check on our documentation or
Google our documentation and sign up and
once you dare will enable you whitelist
you and then the type of image that runs
there is is google container image and
it automatically runs your daugher
contain okay so it was a I feel less bad
okay so for those who aren't necessarily
a part of the Alpha program or have
probably a an investment and say I will
say traditional DevOps type tools so
chef Pat the ansible terraform if people
want to use those tools to do more of a
installment directly on machines
themselves how does that look so well d
can do it in first of all they can do it
directly they can they can load the code
directed the application directly onto
onto the machine using justice sort of
great or baking an image or using
deployment manager disorder tools that
are provided with the platform right but
obviously we are integrated with what
chef Papa terraform deployment manager
and all of these tools have plugins or
connections so that you can use them to
deploy instances that would be part of
the manage instance group and then would
use all of the goodies of the platform
it's it's there it's documentation you
can find all of the documentation on on
our documentation page along with
examples and some cases cool we'll have
linked to all of that documentation do
you have a little bit of a like a view
on what are the tools that people are
actually using mast like what are the do
people use a lot of tariffs or more have
you seen people using puppet monthly so
we've seen a you know it's a fair mix I
think the nice thing about the managed
instance groups is that because they're
just built into GC
self and they're supported by API
g-cloud and you I we have people using
manage instance groups from all of those
entry points so you can basically just
when you're starting out you can go to
the UI and create an instance group
based on a template or you know create
an image create a template creature and
group and that's very easy to get
started with because you kind of see it
feel it you don't get your hands dirty
with this very intuitive view of the
group of instances and then you can kind
of graduate if you want to using g-cloud
if you want to be doing some simple
scripting and that of course if you're
building something more or solid you go
to the API but then what we are seeing
of course with Chef puppet is that
people are creating their own kind of
cookbooks and and scripts and we're
looking at building some of those on our
own as well so that we can really
support the management since groups
that's kind of I would say ok the first
class citizen of these you know
different cookbook so you can just
create a group and have it may be
managed externally and then of course
with even our internal deployment stack
so like the deployment manager you can
use that to create manage instance
groups and that's another common use
case yeah that is a that is marks
favorite product of all Google Club
bathroom he always talks if I do talk
about deployment manager nice nice well
would you like it I just want people to
script their deploys that's all I want
it's restructures code so there is
something that I think is really cool
most people the most people tend to
forget which is you can actually create
manage instance groups with printable
machines right that's right and could
you give us a little bit about could you
talk a little bit about what are the
benefits of this and like real quick why
people would use them I mean the why is
just to save money I mean that's you
know the preamp tubes are there if you
want to save on costs but at the same
time if you're willing to give up the
kind of control of the instances and the
nice thing is that if you use manage
instance groups you already have this
mindset of each instance is replaceable
you know it's stay class I can create
destroy them because they'll just you
know connect get the their work and then
do it and then kind of upload it or
do whatever needs to be done but each
specific instance isn't special and so
if you accept that mindset and now
you're running let's say manage instance
group with like 2,000 instances and any
one of them can be replaced at any time
then suddenly preemptive all makes sense
because well you know maybe preempt a
bunch of them that's okay because auto
scaling or whatever other automation
you're running will just create new ones
and you can keep going and keep working
but you keep your savings awesome um
I've just for fun I want to ask so like
what are the coolest things you've seen
built on top of managed infrastructures
they've been like a particularly awesome
project that you thought was
particularly fascinating well so so
we've seen a couple of interesting
events wonderful it was one of our
colleagues decided when we first rolled
out a better version of autoscaler of
our goal is decided we can actually show
on stage that we we can ramp up to
serving 1 million queries per second
right so we so we did on stage demo
pulling a load generator and starting it
and then creating like from scratch and
manage instance get running off the
shelf apache and loading it with the
load so that it started adding instances
and within six minutes that it was like
adding adding the load was growing
gradually right then within six minutes
we were already supporting 1 billion
queries per second so can you beat that
but what other interesting story it's
one of our customers who was migrating
from portly from on trend and partly
from a different law provider was having
this spiky load and this was like an
application back and so it was super
important for for this customer not to
lose this requests and and this customer
came and said look I really need a
predictive auto scaling and break the
vow to scaling is something where you
would you will be able to say well too
or at 7am I'm going to have to use this
many instances it lists and
automatically adjusted it and we didn't
have it at the time and they told us a
story and the story was well your your
competition also didn't have it so we
ended up disconnecting autoscaler around
the time where we most need it and then
we ended up adding this instance is
manually based on some
back-of-the-envelope calculations that
we tracked in the spreadsheet right it
was a terrible experience so only like
10 mins after the peak has happened we
were reconnecting the autoscaler so that
they would do the cleanup and mostly
like scale down all right so they were
miserable and then so we said well we'll
be happy to work with you but can you
just try our autoscaler and they said no
look you don't understand we've used the
autoscaler on your competitors cloud for
years it's never gonna work in this
condition say well okay we promise we're
gonna build it but just try it right and
a couple of months later we got an email
and evil was just one cent and said
predictive auto scaling is no longer
than necessary thank you nice yes yeah
for mine I think the the coolest thing I
see is some of the things people build
with the custom metric right so auto
scaling everyone understands to be
cpu-bound rate or based or QPS based
which is like traffic but you can
actually code up your old metric which
could be anything you want at all and
scale on that and that's what some of
the customers have been using to build
different q based scaling solutions that
are a little bit smarter so that you
know as the work comes in the metric
gets fig gets calculated and then the
autoscaler just listens to that and then
scales up and down to process the work
you have based on your own definition of
what work means and how much time you
need / Burke you know like work unit and
per instance and I think there's a lot
of flexibility with that because you
can't have that full control of how you
calculate it and then we'll just scale
it based on how you want it scaled and
get through your work and then scale you
down when you don't need the machines
cool I'm actually going to add one more
story gonna do yeah we have we
interviewed Tim Kelton from the caster
labs or there's characters labs
depending of how good or bad your accent
is and they told us about how they were
processing terabytes of maps okay we've
machine instead machinist transcripts
managing sis groups and how they were
very happy with both the load balancer
that at the auto scaling and the
parental machines so if people are
interested in listening a whole story
about about it we have the episode 41
that you should check out so excellent
cool well I think we're running out of
time just a little bit but I give you a
chance just if there's anything that we
haven't mentioned or maybe new things
coming up or basically anything cool and
exciting that you want to make sure hits
our podcast listeners is there anything
else you want to add Papa why don't you
go first sure yeah absolutely we're
always working on new things and are
excited to share them so on my side I
want to share the updater which is now
with alpha and it's also like the other
feature you have to do white listen to
use it but we'll be going to beta very
soon and so what the updater does is it
allows you to roll out a new version of
your software to your manage instance
group in a nicely controlled fashion so
you can control the rate of the update
how many machines can be offline at the
same time how many machines to spin up
extra if you want to always have your
service running maybe you want to do
canary roll out into a partial Rho load
test it for a while so all those
features are available which makes it
super-easy to basically deploy new
versions of your software onto your MIG
without disrupting your service
excellent and New Jersey yeah well the
original manage instance group are going
ga just very GA next week so you can
count on the great all of the great
support and SLA with all of the services
that we already provided in bed cool
which may actually already have gone GA
depending on when we release this
podcast yeah I guess proly if it's next
week proly s so take it out take the
Google cloud block to make sure if that
announcement
be ready awesome well thank you so much
uh to youtube to for taking the time to
tell us a little bit more about managed
instance groups and tell us all the cool
tell us about all the cool things that
people are building thanks for having us
this is always it's always great to talk
managed instance groups awesome thank
you bye thank you thank you spy thanks
so much to both pavel and jersey for
such an interesting interview i think
that it was very enlightening to see
like not everything is koo burnett is
you can go with GCE and do many things
and there's a lot of features that will
help you make GC very manageable that is
upon cuz you know because it's mesh
infrastructure yeah yeah that's good but
I like it I like it well-done okay okay
but i think i think you're right you
know it just goes to the whole continuum
thing as well right if if one of these
things isn't a fit you've got so many
layers and so many levels where you can
come in and be like oh maybe i'll use
this particular one it'll be a better
fit for it or something yeah and as I
was saying that not everything is given
at ease let's go with a question of the
week about Cooper Nettie's hat sir so
the question is okay imagine that we
have a I have a criminai this cluster
and I have a service that exposed and I
expose it to the world but I want to
make sure that only some some specific
eye peas or maybe a range of ips is able
to access it how how do I do that so
it's actually surprisingly easy which is
really really cool you're able to
restrict access to a load balancer
service to an IP address in your llamo
file in the same way is when you need to
find your service there is a argument in
there that you can set called load
balancers source Rangers it's a CIDR
cedar I don't know how you would
pronounce that see idea I cook I process
cider cider cider okay I can work with
that I'd say as if one of those things
you read on the internet but you never
hear someone say out loud so it's an IP
range format for those who aren't
familiar of it so that you can specify
what IP range you want so if you've got
like a specific set maybe a particularly
whitelisted IP or a particular
waitlisted set of ips very similar to do
that it
ends up translating behind the scenes to
being firewall specifications inside
Google Cloud and then you know only
those IP addresses can connect their
services so you have better security if
you want you know only particular things
to access the services you have
available on communities cool I think
that the important thing is that the
same way we're saying that you can do
this in Coober net is very easily this
ends up being translated as just one
more firewall rule that will be applied
to the load balancer generated on Google
compute engine so if you want to do that
by yourself you can also do that if you
know running cover natives and you want
to limit the two to constrain the range
of ips that you have that you're
exposing your service to you can use
g-cloud compute firewall rules and do
exactly the same yeah yeah so it's all
the same things under the hood and if
you're not using communities on us maybe
you're doing it on AWS it's supported
there as well so that's pretty cool as
well cool and the last thing is if you
do these and for any reason you're
running coronaries on a provider that
doesn't support this feature it will
just be ignored so be careful with that
I guess okay excellent all right well
sounds like that will be the end of the
episode which is a little sad but that's
okay i will be joining you shortly in LA
but are you doing anything before the
end of the year or anything special
going on not really i'm just back from a
week in china was awesome we're going to
be this week here in LA and after that
i'm just going to be enjoying my
holidays i'm actually getting ready for
two conferences early next year i will
be at the end of january i will be in
golab io which will be in Florence Italy
and I'm very excited about that one and
then in February early februari i'll be
back to one of my favorite conferences
foss them in Brussels excellent yeah i
think all I'm really doing is ramping up
for next and the FEHB next year and oh
yeah game developers conference this is
just before that here in San Francisco
just a couple big things you know just a
couple of big things exactly cool well
thank you Mark for recording today
remotely
well I guess I am the one that is
recording remotely but thank you anyway
definitely thank you to thank you to
everyone who's listening to us and see
you all next week too
you
[Music]